this Factory in the city of xiamen there
are more than 1 000 workers and most of
them are from mainland China all except
their boss
who is from Taiwan
he was one of the first Taiwanese
investors to come to xiamen more than 30
years ago
we are all Chinese the two sides of the
street are also a family and we have 100
support from our compatriots here
and he says recent tensions in the
region haven't dampened his confidence
in opportunities for collaboration
we always hope that two sides can
integrate and develop and not argue over
trivial matters
Han is the type of success story Beijing
wants to highlight an example of
cross-straight success but his views
don't represent the majority in Taiwan
opinion polls have repeatedly showed
only a small minority support
unification in the long or short term
these tour groups waited eagerly for
their first glimpse of Taiwan it's a
short journey of just three kilometers
from China's Shaman to taiwan's kinman
islands and you can see them just behind
me there this is about as close as we
can get traveling by boat from the
mainland
last month China carried out air and sea
drills its people's Liberation Army or
pla simulating an encirclement of Taiwan
what I expect
moving forward is uh not necessarily
risk of conflict but certainly the
potential for miscalculation for
accidents and for misunderstanding the
current situation is is quite risky in
terms of that lack of Crisis
communication mechanisms between the two
countries and the heightened activity
around Taiwan by the pla
for these Travelers the coast of xiamen
is more a holiday Hot Spot than a
geopolitical flash point but many people
come here just to see Taiwan from a
distance
I hope our motherland will be reunified
soon all Chinese people dream their
bosses
China is developing very well and the
Taiwan is not the Communist party is
doing a very good job
even the children aren't just here for
fun on the beach this group is known as
the young pioneers of the Communist
Party led by Chinese soldiers who are
teaching them about patriotism and
reinforcing the message of one China
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Sherman
China
let's discuss this with Denise Rhodes